[Applause]
thank you I appreciate it
I know it's our this is our last show of
the Season I'm gonna miss you a lot but
I feel like we are leaving on a high
note because hey democracy survived
Trump is humiliated
Putin is getting his ass kicked in the
Ukraine I feel like I'm a star of a
Hallmark holiday movie called
the Christmas surprise
now that we almost and also good news we
were going to have World War III and now
we're not so that's good
um because uh yeah no interesting
no I a missile from the Ukrainian War
landed in Poland which is a NATO country
and everybody was like oh my God is this
going to escalate into World War III
fortunately Biden got on the phone with
both parties settled it down nothing's
going to happen now
and that is tonight's episode of thank
God Trump isn't President
oh
but that's not going to stop him from
trying again he made his big
announcement well not that big did you
see that he announced he's running for
president tomorrow like very low-key
very low energy
sad I thought I mean really did you see
him he looked like a gigolo on his 10th
call of the day
tired I mean
there was six American flags behind him
he didn't hump any of them it was it was
he's so 2000 late this guy you know he's
it's some of yesterday's news like hey
it was like watching a t announce a new
landline
[Applause]
they don't own us anymore right
[Laughter]
and of course had to go through his
Greatest Hits about American Carnage and
he said literally quote our cities are
rotting he said they're cesspools of
blood
and half of Africa was like what and
we're the [ __ ] countries
so the election they're still counting
some places but uh basically the
Democrats kept the Senate the
Republicans won the House of
Representatives there will be a new
speaker Nancy Pelosi is stepping aside
of course she has to Kevin McCarthy from
right here in California will be the new
Speaker of the House Kevin Kevin
McCarthy
a couple of years ago he said I want you
to watch when Nancy Pelosi hands me the
gavel it'll be hard not to hit her with
it
he said that I mean come on it's just a
joke nobody thinks someone would really
go to a Pelosi family member and hit
them with a hammer
thank you
but that's politics that's not what
American cares about all America cares
about is they can't get Taylor Swift
tickets
and Twitter is in chaos and crypto is
tanking which I think is fantastic I
have never been a crypto fan
oh yeah oh yeah we're going to talk
about millions of people have lost
millions of dollars on crypto and a lot
of them are blaming the celebrities who
hyped it
yeah now when married people are having
sex they're both thinking about getting
screwed by Matt Damon